c'est assez rare pour être souligné
trois heures après son allocution
emmanuel macron a dû réécrire un tweet
en fin de soirée à l'adresse de ceux qui
ont vu dans son discours sur la
situation en afghanistan une façon de ne
pas assumer les devoirs de la france
vis-à-vis de l'accueil des réfugiés ce
que j'ai dit ce soir sur l'afghanistan
et que certains veulent détourner la
france fait continuera de faire son
devoir pour protéger celles et ceux qui
sont les plus menacés car une partie de
son discours plaidant pour une réponse
coordonnée de l'europe face à
d'éventuels flux migratoires irréguliers
important est mal passée auprès d'une
partie du public alors même que des
images d'afghans désespéré tentant de
fuir les talibans sont très largement
partagé sur les réseaux sociaux flux
migratoires irréguliers
voilà comment emmanuel macron président
de la république a qualifié ce soir les
femmes les enfants et les hommes qui
veulent quitter l'afghanistan car ils
sont menacés de mort indigne inhumain
irresponsable nous n'oublierons jamais
jamais il n'y aura pas une immigration
massive jo je ne crois pas à cela il
faut raison garder et c'est pour ça que
je qualifiais ou à minima u2 maladresse
les propos du président
il a voulu chasser sur les terres du
front national
alors qu'il y avait un discours plutôt
conciliateur qu'il aurait fallu avoir
sur ce qui se passe de dramatique et qui
est un échec probable la politique
américaine et de la politique européenne
donc française hors de france le lanceur
d'alerté américain exilé en russie
edouard snowdon y allait aussi de son
tweet sur ce passage de l'allocution ce
ne peut pas être vrai si y'a t'il erreur
de traduction parce que là les talibans
sont sur le point de commettre des
représailles et on dirait vraiment que
la priorité de macron et de parler à son
électorat en vue d'élections pas de
sauver des vies en france s'il est une
question clivante par excellence c'est
bien celle de l'immigration et de
l'asile et de l'autre bord politique la
perspective d'une vague d'immigration
afghane inquiète et on ne compte pas
vraiment sur l'europe ni sur emmanuel
macron pour l'empêcher quand je vois je
vais peut-être vous choquer mais quand
je vois les images de tous ces jeunes
hommes qui courent après un avion qui
essayent de décoller j'ai envie de leur
dire quoi vous avez pas défendu votre
pays pourquoi l'armée afghane que la
france et surtout les etats-unis et les
autres pays occidentaux ont équipé
financer entraîner pourquoi aux premiers
combats avec les talibans mais la
déposer les armes voilà s'il est si les
afghans eux-mêmes ne croient pas en leur
pays on n'a pas vocation à les
accueillir en permanence dès qu'il ya un
problème chez eux la france a annoncé le
12 août qu'elle suspendait les
expulsions d'afghans déboutés du droit
d'asile pour raisons de sécurité dès
juillet la suède et la finlande avait
pris des décisions similaires suite à la
demande des autorités afghanes
l'allemagne et les pays bas qui au
départ et chine a adopté cette mesure se
sont finalement aligné le 11 août la
grèce elle estimait alors que l'union
européenne n'avait pas les épaules pour
encaisser une crise migratoire majeur en
europe on le voit les politiques
d'immigration sont souvent source de
dissension et la chute de kaboul
inquiète alors qu'en 2020 les afghans
représentent est déjà à eux seuls un peu
plus de 10% des demandes d'asile dans
l'union européenne soit environ 44 mille
personnes